[Music]
my name is claire van kampen
i'm a playwright director and composer
a fairly recent playwright and i was the
founding musical director at
shakespeare's globe theatre
in 1997. so uh what took you
from composer to playwright
well it's in a sense it's all one being
in the theater
so when i took the decision to move into
the theater
as a musician
i thought well theater is a very
holistic
thing it's not just that i'm i'm not an
actor
so you have a choice you can be a
composer you can be a director you can
write the plays
it's all story so in a sense i was a
composer for
what 40 years so i thought it's time i
do something else as well and i've
always wanted to write
ever since i was very little and i had
to make a choice to become a
professional musician
quite early became a concert pianist
actually
in the royal college of music then a
composer
so gradually i'd be moving towards the
theater sort of in the
latter part of my life how has your
musical background affected your
writing style well i suppose an ear for
dialogue
i listen a lot perhaps i listen more
than i
look or i certainly listen more than
many directors
do directors are by and large visual
people
which is very generalized but on the
whole they're looking at stage pictures
they're looking at where actors are
standing in the
in the stage picture they're not often
listening to the tempo of dialogue and
the way we speak
to each other in a naturalistic sense
and you get wonderful writers like
pinter
of course and shakespeare who knew
exactly how to get dialogue down on a
page
so that's what intrigued me
that's sort of where i began in a sense
how do i get
real people onto the page
how i mean how how is that process of
getting real people on onto the stage
how do you find it
there some writers find it torture well
i'm not
sure well it's a very interesting
question
because at first it feels very natural
you imagine a conversation
often in the street or in cafes or
whatever you
you come across conversations don't you
you've you're not there at the beginning
of them
you come in sort of halfway through and
i've done so many shapes with plays
i've done almost all of them and very
rarely does the scene
start at the top of somebody beginning
to say something often people come on
stage and they're already in
conversation
because that's what we do that's how we
hear life we hear life through fragments
and snatches of conversation
so it seemed to me a very good way to
begin
and so you imagine people together and
what they're talking about
their need to speak i mean why do i need
to tell you this now
you know i have a need to share this
with you so
that's what you want to find as a
playwright or as a writer what's the
need for that person to say what they're
saying
and then what's the other person's
reaction to that need
are they going to be challenged by it
are they going to add to it are they
going to disagree or agree
so you start with all of that now later
on down the line
comes all the difficulties because then
you want to
be sure that you have a story that has
action and that it
really is compelling and moving the
story forward
is the mark of a great writer and i
don't profess to be a great writer yet
what's your what's your process of
editing then
i'm not bad at editing
because as a composer particularly for
the theater you've got to you can't be
proud about it you can't be
egocentric a director says you're going
to have to cut two minutes
because the show's too long
and this cue you know we don't need so
much
now two minutes of music is a lot it can
take
i don't know three days four days to
write two minutes of music
um so you have to kind of swallow your
pride and go
okay the good of the show i'll do it and
so you get into that frame of mind
so when you look at editing you've got
to
not be precious you've got to say what
serves a story what's the audience
understanding
how am i going to give them this story
in the most economical
and powerful way and often you have to
just jettison
all your best bits you think throw them
overboard and actually it's usually the
better for it
okay once you've gone through that
approach so you've been through that
process
you've written something it's there what
unique qualities
does live performance bring well
actually
it's not even in performance it's in
rehearsal because
a play is just that it's playful
it's not a piece of literature and so
often i read scripts that come through
the door
or you read plays and they're so
literary
and players were never supposed to be
that they're supposed to be
real you know how people really behave
so you right you may write it but then
you get it into rehearsal
and you hear it coming out of the actors
mouths and it's that awful kind of
cringe moment you think
this is not how that person should speak
i mean it's way too many words and if
it's a good actor and they usually are
um they'll have great suggestions how
about if i just switch
the sentence round and i start with what
you've written at the end of it
you know for example um
do you think we should go on holiday
next week
it's perhaps more natural to go been
thinking next week
do you think we should go on holiday but
as a writer you might not write it like
that you see what i mean
so it's another step in the process it's
very very exciting
for a writer to meet the actor in
rehearsal and then the next step
is in front of an audience who have not
had
three to six weeks rehearsal with you
they don't know the story they're not
invested
they've paid their money but they want
they want to give you they
you know they want the story from you so
i tend to watch them
quite carefully and um
in previews we've got usually a luxury
whereby we can
cut and change and develop and do a few
rewrites and
it's always the audience i watch in
previews what do you learn from them
i learn where their attention is and
their focus
if they start sort of looking down at
their watch you know i mean that's
that's a kind of bad moment you know i
want them to be leaning forward in their
chairs i want them to be
interested sometimes you can see where
they're confused
where they're watching something and
they're interested then suddenly
you can see that they're thinking you
don't want an audience to do that
you want them to be um you want to be
ahead of them
not behind them you want them to you
want to be leading an audience forward
so they're
excited to know what's going to happen
next
um what are the capabilities
of music in theater
you know i've changed my mind about that
so many times over the course of
my career starting out i used to think
that it was so important and that i
laced
everything with music cues you know and
i kind of could almost told the story
with music you could have taken the
words away and
you know that in my mind um
it varies i think with let's let's look
at shakespeare
i think you shouldn't underscore
shakespeare at all
and yet i did for years and years and
probably until about five years ago
i was doing beautiful cues that told you
how to feel and think
now i think the words are such powerful
pieces of music in themselves you don't
want to get in the way
shakespeare knows when to have music and
when not
and so gradually you begin to have a
sense of where music is helpful and
where it's not
um other pieces that are not
so text-based become very powerful
with great choices of music whether it's
extant music that you
love to use like a piece of philip glass
or something
or whether you get a composer to write
something very specific
for you so it depends but i think
for my sense um
less is always more that's quite a big
shift to have
to have gone from underscoring
shakespeare for the globe
to thinking it shouldn't be there at all
how else is your
are there any other big ways in which
your um perception of theater has
changed over the course of your career
yeah i think it's it's changed and it's
changing because
i just had a really fascinating
discussion actually with
20 people around the table here about um
where they feel that theatre's letting
them down or they're not engaged with
theater
as it is now and it's funny because it's
it's sort of coming around full circle
to something i believed in
quite a long time ago that theater is
trapped in buildings
in a sense theater was never meant to be
in buildings at all it was in the street
and in many countries in the world it
still is in carnival or in
street theater form it doesn't live in
houses
where you go in and sit in the dark and
you watch
a basically a picture on a screen with
3d
people you know actors um
i think it has a place indoors of course
it does that wonderful feeling of
an event that's all happening under a
roof together but that's
rare often you go and it's a dry
experience
you think i paid an awful lot of money
and actually i would have been just as
happy watching
tennis at home on television or sport or
or netflix or something
you ha you feel empty and i think it's
to do with the fact that it has been
taken out of community
whereas it used to be come out of
community in in the real sense that
it was an expression of what that
community was
and i think we have to get back there i
really i don't know how we do it
it needs money funding it needs
attitude changing um but i think that's
where i've seen what the most exciting
theater in my life
is in places that you wouldn't expect
what's been some of the most exciting
theater you've seen
um actually you know punch drunk i don't
know if you
heard of that company um punch junk
many years ago took over an old building
in the east end i think it was a
warehouse
and they did a performance of faust the
foul story
but every floor of the warehouse was
dressed differently
and you went in and it was a sort of um
you took your own journey as a member of
the audience so you're given a mask
so that that told people that you were a
member of the audience
but you were free to roam wherever you
wanted to go in the warehouse that was
clever
because there were there were certain
structures in place
that controlled the audience in here and
there
but basically you followed your instinct
i like that actor where is he going i'm
going to follow him
you'd find he'd come across a scene that
was being played
it was very very clever and it's
another form of another punch junk show
is still going on in new york i think
it's been going on now for
six years or so called sleep no more
which is the story of
macbeth in an old hotel that was sort of
about to be condemned or changed and
they're still there so that tells me
that people want it
people want an experience they don't
just want to look at something they want
to be part of it and
feel it sensually and be free to choose
options choices it's an interactive
experience
but there's a big growth in experience
culture at the moment from like uh
websites like airbnb
to events like you know secret cinema
do you think theater risks being like
left behind
i think it does i think at the moment it
the it's there's a fork in the road
um it can either get so commercialized
that we're only going to we're paying
huge sums of money to see stars
on stage uh or
popular books that have been made into
plays like harry potter which is a very
good experience and then the rest of it
is sort of lots of different options
that are mainly
fringe oriented where for example the
vaults
in waterloo very exciting
you go there it's very varied you may
get a fantastic
show followed by a show that you don't
quite understand maybe not so good
but that's a happening thing you know
it's pretty packed
there's you can eat you can drink you
know it's
i think what's dangerous is the
commercial road is going to be so
exclusive
there are less and less people that are
going to be able to go to
west end theaters even with somebody
like sonia friedman who
gives you know what 25
or 100 tickets at an incredibly cheap
price if you turn up on the day
even with something like that it's going
to become so exclusive
that it's really not fired by
normal people in the community it's um
it's only a very small part of society
that that can take part in that kind of
theater
so i don't know where we're going with
it i'd love to see
a middle ground where there was funding
as
a long time ago in my life there was you
could take a risk
and you wouldn't lose your shirt um you
would have the right to what you would
call
fail although i don't think there's any
sense of failure
in experimentation but you could
try different things and i think that's
how we grow
and how we learn about art and culture
if you don't have access to any kind of
funding
and you can only do romeo and juliet
because you need the footfall
to pay for it where are we going
and what what are we doing why are we
doing theater at all
so i am it's my personal belief
shared by not not only of you that the
government should stop spending billions
on
defense and actually spend a little bit
of money on art and culture
i think that would be really great i
agree
um can we can sorry your attitude
towards failure
sounds interesting can you talk a bit
more about that maybe
i think that our education system um
programs us to fail to feel that we fail
um from an early age i think it is very
poor
um we're
we're asked to to take part in exams
that have a structure
very early on as children we're asked to
stop playing
and to start learning you know which
means we have to work
for something that will get marked
ticked
um we have scores and this sets up
a feeling that we we've got to do it
right
you can't fail you mustn't get a bad
score or
you you know i think the programming of
children
and teenagers in our
kind of education system is incredibly
flawed
and this leads to the fact that
you can't just take a risk in your
workplace whatever it is you can't try
something
because you haven't actually got the
mindset
that is expansive enough to embrace
experimentation
and something that may not work but
you've tried it
you are not going to try that oh don't i
whenever i go and work in america
weirdly that
doesn't have a fantastic education
system but it has a much more of a
can-do culture that's built into it
if i opera offer up an idea the response
is always
oh oh that's interesting how are you
going to do that
how do you want to make that work here
it's not that
it's oh i don't know i don't know if
we've got the money to do that
oh do you think that's going to work
it's the way we're programmed
early on and i i think it's um
it's almost like a built-in um
expectation of of failure that stops us
growing and taking a risk and
daring to fail
[Music]
what theatre would you recommend what
plays would you
suggest people go see or try read
if you would recommend that for someone
who's not
who wants to get into it but hasn't had
the opportunity to yeah
it's a very very good question because
so much of theatre
is reflective of well
i mean depending where it is we're
talking often about london
but we've become very london centric in
our arts
i don't know if someone on time's side
would have the same
views as me down in london they may or
they may not
um i don't know how much theater or
access to theater they would get
going up to tyneside now where's the
funding
so let's look at london uh
obviously the globe you can pay five
pounds
you can walk in with a beer um no one's
going to tell you not to
you can leave if you're bored
you can stay for 10 minutes you can stay
for an hour you can stay for three hours
it's it's very easy yeah you have to
stand
but i mean actually if you're interested
in what you're looking at and hearing
that that feels like nothing and you've
got the advantage of
maybe actors coming through the yard and
you feeling that you're part of
something
i think the globe's doing a great thing
at the moment by um
it sounds such a cliche cliche but
embracing diversity in
all areas looking at actors that have
not been given opportunities because
they're not what we
would call able-bodied you know that
they are physically challenged or that
they are deaf
or you know they can't see very well
these actors haven't had opportunities
and the globe is
giving them not only opportunities but
actually welcoming
all kinds of people into companies that
were never given opportunities before
and people in the audience see that and
feel that that's reflective of
who we are so i'm hoping that will grow
and that people will see the globe as
their theater as they once did
what do you have in store next well at
the at the globe are you passing me
personally
um well my links will with the globe
will never
be broken um because i was there at the
beginning
so it's it's almost like a a child that
you've seen grow
but um personally i'm moving into
directing a film
really you know can you talk about it
yeah okay
i've um i'm i've written the screenplay
and i'm
directing a film about the artist elaine
de kooning
who is married to william de kooning and
it's about you know women that weren't
seen
and and and her history is kind of
forgotten
i mean there was a great lee krasner
exhibition recently at
uh the barbican which you know you've
only got to see one of her paintings to
know how
brilliant she was but she was married to
jackson pollock
you know that was a great degree of
difficulty
and um the same with elaine de kooning
she was in the shadow of a very tall
tree
so these women have kind of got lost in
the kind of sea of
the abstract expressionists and history
so i'm very thrilled that someone asked
me to do this
and it's extremely scary and
thrilling at the same time to be
directing a film yeah are you entering
production soon or is it
um we'll be doing pre-production very
soon and we're shooting it next year
yeah how lastly have you found the
process it's probably a big question so
lastly but
the process of taking a screenplay and
turning it or being about to sign into a
film versus taking a script and turning
it into
live performance theater well it's the
second
script i've turned into well i turned my
play into a screenplay
um you know so yeah i'm very new at it
i have no idea how it will be i hope i
hope it'll be something people want to
see
but you know there again i'm taking a
risk
but i feel i'm too old not to
claire thank you so much you're welcome
thank you for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute
of art and ideas at iai tv
you